i just wrote this one and this is what
it's like to go out to dinner with my
wife
[Music]
she's not here i can say whatever i want
here we go
and here we are
out to dinner
say you're watching your figure
[Music]
she orders a salad
and here we are
waiter brings the
food she says mine looks good
and she reaches for my
place
don't want to share my fries with you
you should've ordered fries why didn't
you
you know you like these fries you know
what you should do
order up some fries that are just for
you
don't want to share my fries with you
don't want to share my
fries
[Music]
and here we are
home from the date
she says it is getting late
she goes to bed
and i crawl in
i am horny
i pull her
toward me
and she says
not tonight
[Music]
i'm not really in the mood aren't you
maybe if i'd had more food
i would do
probably just one fry or two
and i'd be right on top of you
you should probably share your fries
shouldn't you
you should probably share your
[Music]
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]